[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to chess
openings explained
as always my name is caleb denby and
tonight i am continuing my f3 nimzo
series
with again talking about the same fourth
move
by black which is the move d5 we covered
lines appearing after this move d5 in
the first two lectures
but d5 far and away is the most popular
response
to this opening and it turns out there
are really three main different ways
that the game can go
so we've already covered two of those
and tonight we are going to look
at the sort of third option for black
after the move d5
and it really is a pretty drastic
difference compared to the first two
lines that we took a look at
so why don't we just jump right into it
um this option
by black was chosen by magnus carlson on
occasion and we'll see it actually
appears
in the candidates however it is a line
that is very much not the most common at
the amateur level
why is that well optically it looks very
very good for white
at first glance and if black isn't
careful then it can in fact
just be very very good for white if not
winning
and that's sort of what magnus ran into
in this game against ikaro of course
you can see the result on your screen
this game is
from zurich in 2014 and i think that was
still back in the day
when naca maybe had this psychological
block against magnus
where seemingly every game when he got a
reasonable position
somehow it ended up going the other way
but that being said hikaru did play very
well in the opening
in the middle even the middle game and
was in a winning position against magnus
so let's see how he arrived there
the line of course starts with d4 and we
go into
the nimzo india here and after f3
again talking about this move for d5
on day one we looked at what happened
after of course a3
and we saw bishop c3 bc3 and
you know for example castles and e takes
d5
or i think a bit better for black is
takes takes
and c5 with knight takes d5 in response
to c takes d5
but here black actually has a very
surprising third
option and that is quite perplexingly to
retreat
the bishop now why is this so confusing
looking well
it's a little bit strange often to move
the same piece twice in the opening
and it's especially strange to bring it
out to b4 and then bring it back to a
square like e7
so early on and it's even stranger when
you combine it with this move d5
why is that so weird well you put this
bishop here to challenge this knight to
pin this knight to the king
and as part of that you weaken uh
white's control over the light squares
in the center you weaken the control
over e4 that's why by far the more
popular option is to take this knight on
c3
you're playing d5 fighting white for
control of the e4 square
and so it makes sense to trade off this
dark squared bishop for this knight
in order to sort of solidify your
control over this square
now we've seen in especially the e takes
d5 line
it can be very difficult for black to
keep control over this square
and perhaps part of that is perhaps that
is part of the reason why
retreating the bishop is also a very
reasonable option like i said
i think this line may be more common at
the top level
than some of those other options after
d5 but
definitely at least from my anecdotal
experience
this has not been the most most common
move that i face
and when i do face it usually somehow
practically over the board it is very
difficult for black to navigate the
complications
now black did not challenge us most
the most direct way by capturing our
knight and so this
does in fact just give us the liberty to
play the move e4
sort of without consequence here uh
black
lost uh their chance to take off this
knight and using this knight's support
we can play the move e4 quite
comfortably now
and to start with i want to look at d
takes e4
this is really the only uh real idea
after bishop e7
uh later in the lecture i think last if
we have time i'm going to take a look at
why c5 isn't played here why keeping the
tension is bad
and the answer is basically you can play
with the c5 idea but if you do
the bishop is a bit better actually on
the surprising d6 square but
that's for later for now we're looking
at the main line which goes e4
black goes ahead and captures on e4 we
see
f takes e4 and now the point of black's
play is sort of revealed black
has kept the dark squared bishop because
black is planning to launch an attack
not on the light squares but on the dark
squares
so black's most common break is this
break of e5
and after e5 of course white wants to
maintain the beautiful pawn center
so white should go d5 now the main idea
of this opening is what magnus carlsen
played next which is moving the bishop
in astounding
third time in the opening bringing it
back out to c5
now that this dark squared weakness has
been provoked
and this is very much i think a surprise
weapon for for many players
with the black pieces the f3 nimzo isn't
exactly the most common opening you face
when you play the nimzo indian
with black and uh sort of having this
you know up your sleeves can be a nice
way to surprise white
if they come in a little bit unprepared
this isn't probably
at the top of the list for most players
you know trying to learn the f3 nimzo
so what's the idea of bishop c5 well of
course it's that
by moving this f pawn moving this e pawn
and moving this d-pawn
so far forward in the case of the f-pawn
getting traded off
these dark squares have become
criminally weak
and black is just looking to exploit
this at
all costs early early on of course
though this comes with a pretty massive
downside
and that downside is this pawn trio in
the center
in openings like the king's indian
defense of course white is also getting
this this pawn trio in the center
but you'll notice a critical pawn for
black is sort of missing without this d6
pawn
this structure is just very very good
for white in the center
so really all the pressure is going to
be on black
in most cases to sort of make something
happen here or else white's central
presence
is really going to be felt and the open
f file
may turn out to benefit white and not
black if black doesn't pose immediate
problems in the opening
now in the game that i'm looking at here
hikaru nakamura actually plays the move
bishop g5
and at first glance this move seems fine
but i do think this is a little bit of
an
inaccurate move order by white
what i'm going to recommend here is the
move knight f3
now does anybody have a guess as to why
i think knight f3
might be better what does bishop g5
allow
that knight f3 does not allow i'm going
to turn it over to you chatroom
can you find the idea here
jorge says caruana alexandco is a good
game in this variation
and jorge is seeing the future i will be
going over that game tonight
although alex zenko did not choose this
e5 idea he chose a relatively new
idea that we definitely need to take a
look at
is the bishop c5 a mistake why can play
b4 expand well it's not
quite that simple so amazingly
shockingly after playing bishop b4
bishop e7 bishop
c5 i think black's path to equality here
comes with the fourth bishop move
bishop to d4 and this is going to be
black's plan if white were to try the
move b4
as well like i said
white's dark squares are criminally weak
with this setup right
there's just no way a pawn can control
any of these squares
uh in the white camp and that's what
black looks to exploit so i like knight
f3
to prevent this bishop d4 idea why is
this so powerful
well if you try something like 92
then believe it or not this is a strong
idea with knight e4 to follow
notably that is not a strong idea here
because king takes f2 and you are
guarding this pawn so it's not really an
option
for white to move this knight because
bishop f2 is going to be a good move
now if you don't move the knight you
play something like knight f3
then it does sort of force the issue
with this bishop but i think after
bishop takes c3
b takes c3 now totaling one
two three four five bishop moves i think
black
may very seriously at least be equal and
and could even consider himself better
after the move queen d6 when black is
still taking over every dark square on
the board
and white structure is going to actually
have a few weaknesses
with the double c pawns in the e pawn
without an f pawn
to support it so i don't really like
allowing this move bishop d4
that's that's sort of the short of it
and bishop g5 isn't actually the most
common move in the position
um i think for this reason by the way
i should say bishop d4 is playable
immediately but but maybe even more
accurate for black is to insert
h6 and bishop h4 and only then go go
with bishop
to uh to d4 but i think that the
difference is is pretty minuscule
so the point is i'm recommending this
move knight f3
what's the downside to knight f3 well it
allows the knight g4 line which we are
going to look at a little bit later
but this knight g4 line i think could
very seriously be winning for white
with with accurate play so
let us stick with this knight f3 move
order just to not get confused and we're
going to transpose back to the game
very very shortly the main move by far
is bishop g4 sort of renewing some ideas
of controlling the d4 square
and i think the best line for white is
to simply go h3
uh you put the question to the bishop
and black is really very much just
playing for control of this square
and bishop takes f3 i think is is by far
the best move
if black were to retreat the bishop i
think white should very simply play g4
and after bishop g6 now we can start
evicting this bishop
thanks to our good control over d4 and i
think
white is is very seriously better here
just for example bishop retreats
bishop d3 and this is going to be a
tough position
for black with like i said this central
control
so in the in the game we did see bishop
takes on
f3 of course we haven't quite transposed
just yet
when after knight bd7 uh bishop g5 this
was in fact a position in the game
of course in the game we just saw that
black castled
after bishop g5 just to show you the
real continuation this is how we got
here we saw bishop g5
castles knight f3 bishop g4 and after
knight bd7 uh the exact same position
magnus just sort of
did not go for the bishop d4 idea and
allowed white to transpose
back to here when after bishop g5 black
does castle
uh now what's going to be the idea for
white well thanks to the central
majority white can actually just castle
queen side
it's not going to be very clear how
black manages to organize an attack just
yet
and in the meantime white's play is
going to be very very clear
on the king's side with pushing forward
and the good news
about this variation is basically
in every uh line that you get
after this idea of e5 and d5 white's
play is going to look very very similar
once you navigate a few opening tricks
make it a few more moves deeper into the
game white's plan
is most for the most part at least
really going to look like this
when you develop out bishop g5 knight f3
you
move the queen usually recapturing an f3
but if you can't just to d2 or c2
and then you castle queen sight and push
on the king's side it's it's kind of
a simple middle game plan for white
which is why i think this main line of
the variation which is
by far the most popular way this is
played with black
i think this just isn't so dangerous for
white if you know
just a few moves of theory to to get you
through
so let's get back to the game we saw
this position and
hicaro does queen side castle and now
black
decides bishop d4 the time is right for
this
move now notably
i haven't really been concerned about
bishop d4 after this trade of bishop g4
h3 takes and takes you might be asking
yourself
well why doesn't black just play bishop
d4 right away
well the answer is for now we still have
this bishop on c1
so knight e2 could just be quite
powerful in this case even knight b5
may be a powerful move but the point is
you're not snagging
my pawn on b2 you might be thinking well
that's fine but after bishop g5 why not
bishop d4
here and the point again is actually
going to be this move knight e2
when quite critically with a few pieces
off the board bishop takes b2 is no
longer really a good move
we can take advantage of the fact that
our queen guards a3 and
activator rook on the b file and after
bishop d4
it's as simple as taking this taking
this pawn
i believe maybe you insert this move as
well when after something like this
uh let's say gf6 knight d4 and ed4
you can just go ahead and recapture the
pawn back on b7
and actually i take it all back just
take on just take on d4 first
go bishop d3 and white is is going to be
better here with the active rook
and this pawn is likely going to die on
d4 or this pawn is going to die
on uh on b7 once again
these three pawns just going to be
powerful for white
so that's why i like this move order
basically we make sure bishop d4
is not really going to be a problem at
any moment here
and you'll see in the games that
actually get played bishop d4 has never
really
played this early on because 92 is just
always a comfortable response
okay so queen side castles then magnus
does go for bishop d4 and again knight
e2
now of course bishop b2 isn't even an
option because we have already castle
queenside
and magnus chooses to cement this bishop
on d4
with the move c5 and already after c5 i
think white
has a very very pleasant advantage white
uh i i think should be close to just
positionally winning it
already on move 14 against magnus
carlsen which is no easy feat
but i think hicaro did manage to get
very close to a winning position
already out of this game what's the
problem
well the problem is after c5 this pawn
is never really going to be challenged
right you can never go
with something like c6 in some positions
to challenge this pawn
and also we'll see that the queen slide
is is getting pretty locked down
after c5 it's going to be difficult to
attack the white king
after this move c5 meanwhile white's
play on the king's side
is still very fluid and very comfortable
to find and that's exactly how this game
develops
that being said black is sort of left
without an option at this point
the backup option is to play some
nothing move like rookie eight
when already white can simply just win a
pawn in the center
and play with this nice central majority
once again and be pretty significantly
better
um that being said black would get some
counter play on white's center as
well and it is a pawn it's not a pawn
for nothing
but it is a comfortable pawn for white
in the game
magnus chose to try to keep the material
with the move c5
and hikaru just continues with the move
g4 we see a5 now
by black the idea of activating the rook
on the a file
king b1 is always an improving move for
white whenever you castle a queen slide
like this
rook a6 was played now knight g3 and
hikaru has has totally taken over on the
king's side and this
is sort of in the back or at least so
everybody thought
of course that is not the result of this
game but we'll see a car who did manage
to get
quite a convincing winning position the
game continued with h4a4
caro again just playing very natural
moves on the king's side
pushing his kingside pawns opening up
files just the classic idea
when you have opposite sides castling
rook h2 was played by akaru which is a
pretty good move to add some support to
the b2 pawn
we see queen a5 by magnus
and i'll just quickly play through a few
more moves it's not super
relevant to the opening theory basically
the plan to remember
is just pushing on the king's side
trying to check mate black
uh the details are going to vary as they
always do in chess but this is the
general idea to remember here
bishop b2 and hikaru simply doubles on
the h
file and that's at this point it's just
you know 2800 level play
uh or at least you know high 2700 level
play top 10 in the world level play
where they just attack each other with
ease and then everybody understands that
it's really good
for white for some reason and then after
queen h4
we get like this sacrifice on b2 but it
doesn't matter white's just checkmating
queen g6 knight f5 the game is like over
now
white clearly has been winning the whole
time queen h3 queen g6
and then all of a sudden out of nowhere
uh hikaru blunders with
with d6 and magnus gets back into the
game and
somehow manages to to win this position
somehow some some
way just for your information i think
rook h1 was the simplest way to win
what's the difference
well the difference is now after the
same line
there's no check on d1 and that matters
for some reason
anyways this is a little bit beside the
point the point of this lecture is not
to talk about this game and how car
lost a winning position the point is the
opening and so what happened in the
opening
to recap we saw this bishop e7 move
giving up control of e4
so white plays e4 we see black fighting
back for the dark squares with e5
so white pushes d5 bishop c5 to take
advantage
i recommend this move order with knight
f3 card shows bishop g5 in the game
the point of knight f3 to stop bishop d4
make sure it's never a good move for
black
bishop g4 threatening this h3 removing
the threat
bishop takes f3 queen takes f3 now we're
still not worried about it thanks to our
bishop still on c1
knight bd7 bishop g5 we're still not
worried about bishop d4
because knight e2 is still a good move
with rook b1 to follow
uh castles castles and then here we
finally did see bishop d4 anyways
and c5 unfortunately just locked the
position on the clean side a bit too
much
and hikaru was able to push on the
king's side and get a winning
position so does anyone have questions
on how this game
developed i think this is going to be
what the vast majority of your games in
this line
actually look like i think this bishop
g4 idea is really the only serious
idea in in my opinion for black after
this move e5
at least and so this is going to be
really
really important it's by far the most
popular option for black
in this bishop e7 line and so it's
important to understand this well
uh so any questions from the chat room
send them my way right now
send them my way
why is taking on f3 with the queen
better than taking on the pawn
well taking with the pawn would actually
completely shred your dark squares
for the moment uh white still has
one last little pawn that can defend
squares like f4 and
uh h4 after this move you have no
control over any of these squares like
ever again
so taking with the queen keeps the dark
squares under control
it's not like the worst move of all time
but definitely i think even the
immediate knight h5
may be a good option for for black here
so queen takes
guards a few more of the the dark
squares also provides some support to
this knight on c3
provides some pressure on the f-file
it's sort of just a nice developing move
[Music]
do i recommend to take the d4 bishop
with the knight immediately well
the point is often to make sure bishop
d4 is a bad move so with knight f3
the point here is yeah you can just take
on d4 and queen takes d4 when
wins upon
any interesting sacrifices well we'll
get to the knight g4 line because
knight g4 here and not bishop g4 is
going to be the line with all the
interesting sacrifices
but fortunately i think most of them if
not all of them are kind of just losing
for black so let us move along then
one last recap bishop g4 here and the
point
for white is to first in the opening
really make sure bishop d4
is never a problem and after that castle
queensland expand on the king's side and
play for checkmate
on that side of the board but let us
move on
to our second game and second idea of
the knight which is going to be
as i have said this idea of knight g4 so
we get all the same opening moves the
bishop comes back to e7
e4 takes takes e5 d5 bishop
to c5 knight f3 is the move order i'm
recommending
and like i said the slight disadvantage
to this
is that it is compared to bishop g5 is
that it does allow the knight to step to
g4
and this is the move that could cause
you some problems
if you're a little bit more a little bit
less than fully prepared
for the road ahead here so what's the
big deal with this move
well it's making a very simple threat
your dark squares are weak
so black is going to attack them and
just very directly
try to shove this knight onto onto the
f2 square
and take your rook for free so what
should you do about this
well i think the best line for white is
actually to go with b4 knight a4 may
also be very good for white it's the
slightly more popular move but i think
the lines with b4
are actually a little bit simpler that's
not to say they're totally simple but
they are a bit simpler than knight a4 i
believe
so i like going b4 right away what's the
point of b4 well the point is
you are prematurely getting rid of this
knight's defender right
the knight still tries to step to f2 you
can just go queen c2
and now there's no time to take this
work on h1 because this piece will be
hanging and this knight will be
a little bit trapped uh if you try to
save this bishop by the way it's a lost
cause
c5 is coming if you try to go to d4 well
that's why this knight is on f3
right and this would be a very very good
position for white
when now black has no presence in the
center
at all so the point with b4
is you are preemptively
preventing knight f2 by getting rid of
its supporting piece here on
c5 now of course there is a downside to
b4
which is black has not yet played the
move knight f2
and that means bishop f2 is a legal move
and this is really
the only try for for black in this
position
if you retreat back to e7 then this
knight makes no sense on g4
bishop e3 is surprisingly maybe a
playable move
but simple moves here lead to an
advantage for white such as a move like
queen d3
or takes in queen d2 i like queen d3 the
best and
trade trade again this knight is just
not going to make sense
on the g4 square so bishop f2
really the only move that makes sense in
this knight g4 line
now of course this makes us lose our
castling rights
the best move by far is king e2 why is
king e2 better than king d2
well for one you're losing control of
the dark squares
and so it doesn't make as much sense to
have your king on a dark square
secondly while it might be tempting to
try to run the king to the queen's side
white's king is actually not going to be
in that much danger here
like i said it really pays to have the
central advantage
and because of this white's king is
going to be relatively safe right he's
got the p
the knights develops you've got the
central advantage the center is closed
white is going to be doing okay in the
center for the moment so
why is king e2 better well it does
introduce a threat of king takes f2
of course i mean that after the move h3
so the point here
is that white is very seriously making a
threat if black plays something simple
like castles
you have to understand that this is just
losing a piece thanks to this idea of h3
uh i guess black can save the piece with
bishop d4 but then once again
this is always going to be a great great
great position
for white with the extra pawns in the
center
this is just completely crushing so
black really only has one serious move
in this position
not castles giving up material uh and
that move is
c5 what's the point of c5 well it's to
respond to h3
with bishop d4 and not be losing the
pawn like we just saw
why doesn't the move bishop h4 look any
good well
white can simply go g3 and now
reclaiming the dark squares
uh white is once again going to be
significantly better the loss of
castling rights here
is not very great when white is able to
again just sort of
completely take over on those weak dark
squares that he once had
so c5 only real idea in this line
and it turns out there's a lot of this
going on in these variations
it seems like black should have a few
different options but really there's
only one move for black that doesn't
immediately lose the game and that's
going to be the case in many many many
of the lines that we look at here
so i want to mention that i think knight
b5
is perhaps the simple choice for white
here so
if you want to take the easy way out and
don't want to learn any more theory
you can play this move
of knight b5 and i think this is a bit
simpler
black's really only idea is to go a6 now
queen a4 by white
a takes b5 queen takes a8s
and then the game will basically
continue black is eventually going to
play bishop d4
you're going to take it you kick the
night out and then develop your pieces
so
if you sort of want to take the simpler
way out i think this is okay
for white i haven't gone super in depth
into this line
because i think by far the best move is
to just take on c6
so i think taking on c6 leads to an
advantage
for white at least a small one uh and i
think this is the best that white can do
in the position so that's the move that
i recommend
so what is happening after d takes c6
well as someone in the chat mentioned
takes on bassant of course
is legal it wasn't a great idea in the
carlson game because we wanted the
center closed with our king stuck
on the queen side and we wanted to just
checkmate on the king's side
here it is a good idea because this
bishop is very very
very short on squares h3 is a huge
threat
so it's in our best interest to renew
this threat on the d4 square we don't
want to give out control of this square
just yet now there are two moves that
can be played here
for black the simple idea is
knight takes c6 when white is simply
going to trade the queens
play this move h3 and after bishop d4
just go bishop d2 and white should have
a comfortable edge here
uh just as an example line knight f6
rook d1 i think is the best move and
after something like bishop e6
at first glance it looks like this could
be awkward for white to meet
but again the idea is going to be to
take control of d4
with the move b5 and this move should
give white a pretty comfortable edge
here
for example taking this is possible
when king e1 would be played for example
bishop b3
and i don't want to get too stuck in the
weeds here but the long and short of it
is eventually white is going to take on
d4
and this is going to grant some
advantage to
white just just taking this pawn in the
center of the board
notably also hitting this knight on on
a5 and this bishop on b3
and all of the lines basically work out
in white's favor here you just play b5
and take on d4 so i think though most
people aren't going to play knight takes
c6 here i think they're going to go
bishop d4
this is a little bit of a better try why
is it a better try because white only
has one move
to be better and the rest of the moves
are good for black
so chat room see if you can figure it
out here
white to move and basically get a
winning advantage
um see what you can figure out
hello everyone in the chat by the way
hello pippenchuck thanks
for making time to watch this lecture
taseo says uh they loved the old days
when volkov
uh and melaniac crushed it with the f3
nimzo
i'm familiar with volkov this guy has
all the games in the database like ever
but uh milleniuk is a new name to me
i'll have to look up some games
so the chat actually has it correct here
the best move
for white and really the only move to
have any kind of advantage
is the strange strange-looking c7 you
take on c6 and then play c7
what's the idea well if you're paying
attention it probably makes sense
the idea once again is to take over the
d for a square
this is sort of the battle of this e5
bishop c5 line who can control d4
and the good news for white is that
often times black just cannot control
this square
or as in the magnus carlsen game can't
really make
make any use of it right you have to
close down the center and then you get
checkmated on the king's side
so c7 here is the move of course this is
a
fork so the only move for black is to
capture
and now knight d5 is the continuation
uh here this position has actually been
only been reached
twice in both games black went queen d8
if the queen tries to take on c4
the move is actually going to be not
king e1 which would
run into trouble after bishop d2 bishop
f2 but but king d2
and what's the point here well the point
is if the queen retreats
we can take this bishop first then
believe it or not white has the winning
move
bishop b5 with a fork to follow
notably this queen actually has no other
retreating moves on the board
and that'll be the match that's that's
just going to be winning
for white uh the best
that black can do is either just
sacrifice this bishop for the e4 pawn
or sacrifice the queen for for the
knight in the rook but both of these
lines
are just going to be winning for the
white pieces here so queen takes c4
actually can't be played because this
move king d2 is sort of shockingly
trapping the queen in a sense so queen
d8
is the move now knight takes d4 of
course is our point
and queen takes d4 and
uh in the game we're looking at sorry i
didn't even introduce the players uh it
was
uh mark bloofstein who is a
random 2548 2550 against uh
thavindir thavindiran who is a 2200
it doesn't really matter that these
players are so low level i picked the
game because they did play
very well in the opening and i think
this is sort of uh illustrative
of how white should be treating the
position mark did his prep
apparently and yeah white is just
winning here it's it's something like
plus two
uh white is up a pawn to start with
secondly this knight is here forever
and it is very very powerful and the
loss of castling rights isn't going to
be relevant
uh white just needs to consolidate a
little bit and develop the pieces let's
see how mark did it after castles we see
h3 black included knight c6 so white
retreats the queen
and black went for queen h4 trying to
keep the threats up
but like i said having this g pawn
around can be quite useful
and here white does play g3 just to take
back some of these squares
queen h5 knight f4 was played queen e5
was played
and after takes takes king e3 now
and white is firmly in control
keeping the extra pawn keeping control
of the center and
this is pretty much a winning position
and mark did go on
to to win this game so let's recap
how did we get here well we are looking
at
not the idea of bishop g4 that we saw in
the first game but the idea of knight g4
directly going after this f2 square
the way to respond to this is to
immediately challenge the bishop i
recommend with the move b4
forcing the move bishop f2 check
king e2 to keep contact with the bishop
now and the only move for black now is
c5 fighting for the d4 square we are not
going to give it up without a fight
go d takes c if black takes on c6
then we're going to take on d8 go h3 and
just play simple
developing moves if uh the more testing
option
bishop d4 the really critical move here
for white again
this move c7 forking the pieces queen
takes
knight d5 thanks to some tactics on the
c4 square
queen d8 takes takes takes and then it's
just a matter of consolidating
getting your pieces into the game and
white will be
winning so questions on the tricky
tricky tricky
knight g4 line questions here
questions here
so articum says you have to know all
this before you allow
knight g4 and yes and no uh it's
i think you would have a very very
difficult time uh dealing with knight g4
if you had never been exposed to any of
these lines
but i don't think this is something that
requires a lot of memorization
right everything sort of follows logical
steps as you go
you need to deal with this bishop so b4
is logical you want to keep in contact
with the bishop so king e2 makes sense
and then it's just a matter of playing
the most aggressive moves to fight for
control of d4
right d takes c6 most aggressive um c7
is a tactic that you need to find and
then knight d5 i guess is also a tactic
that that you need to find
but that that's pretty much all the hard
work for white here
so chess king asks how many more lines
are there
i have four more chapters in my lead
chess study but i promise it gets a
little bit easier
from here on out so we've looked now
at the idea of bishop g4
after knight f3 and the idea of knight
g4 after
knight f3 and those are really the the
two main deferring options you have to
deal with after e5
however i always like to include
sort of the more general case which is
what happens if black just sort of gets
to this position
and then doesn't do doesn't do what you
expect right doesn't go for bishop g4
doesn't go for knight g4
does something entirely different so
let's take a quick look at that
i don't have an example game but i do
just want to introduce some lines
so here we're going to look at what
happens if black goes down this path
bishop b7 e4 takes takes e5 d5
and then decides nah i was kidding i
trust that you are
more prepared than me in bishop c5 i'm
just going to castle
and play chess and again
this sort of falls falls down the road
of any of these moves castles is
reasonable
a5 is reasonable something like c6 is
reasonable
and the good news for white is that your
your play doesn't really have to to be
too different uh
what do i mean by that well it's sort of
like you play the same way
that you would normally play against
bishop c5 but black just doesn't have
any of the
any of the same threats let's just take
a look at a few examples here
let's say castles still knight f3 makes
sense controlling dark squares
bishop g4 you still go h3 takes takes
knight bd7 bishop d3 and now if bishop
c5 you can just go
with something simple like bishop e3 and
white is going to be doing perfectly
fine here with again this nice central
majority
black was unable to make any early
threats and if black doesn't make
anything early on i
do think the position is just going to
favor white thanks to this nice pleasant
central structure that white has created
again
we're going to castle queen side and
push on the king's side of the board
let's say instead a5 happens again i
think knight f3 makes sense
castles again we're just going to
develop with something like bishop d3
again of something like bishop g4 it's
going to be very very similar to what we
just looked at
and eventually i think bishop c5 is
going to come
here again i like the move bishop g5 h6
and apd7 and again we are going to
castle queen side
and push on the king's side now you know
your move orders
are are probably going to change a
little bit depending on what black does
but the point is without this early
bishop c5 and knight g4 bishop g4 ideas
black really simply has no tricks so you
can just develop
as you normally would against the more
testing variations and get a totally
fine position that's the point
i'm trying to get across here so
any questions on this sort of more
general case
what happens if black doesn't go bishop
c5 and just develops
really quickly
so pip and chuck says um what happens
if let's say castle's knight f3
um i guess he's saying something like
knight bd7 here uh
you do have to contend with this idea
saying 98 uh let's say
we we continue like we have been doing
with something like bishop e3
knight d6 let's say something you know
i guess i'll say sort of naive like
queen e2 i think honestly queen c2 might
be the move to put a stop to your ideas
yeah i just don't think this f5 idea is
achievable like let's say you prepare it
like this i queenside castle you go f5
i think you're sort of pushing on the
wrong side of the board here while you
are sort of
contesting the center uh this is the
idea that pippin chuck has
uh i think suggested
uh but i think you're just pushing on
the wrong side of the board white is
happy to open things up
and i think again you're going to run
and do some attacks
on on the king's side of the board here
so white could play like this theoretic
black could play like this theoretically
but again
i really don't think it changes much for
white you still cast a queen slide
develop your pieces
and push on the king's side of the board
and you have a very good position
uh okay so with that let's move on to
something else
entirely what do i mean by that well
let me just say that after bishop e7
this position has been reached
466 times according to my database here
and in almost all of those cases let's
say
307 e5 has been the choice
so what does that math work out to
yeah about three out of every four games
in this bishop b7 line at the top level
are going with this e5 variation so
that's why i spent so much time on it
however there are other ideas that exist
in the position
and i want to go over those quite
notably
in this year's candidates we saw
one such idea between fabiano caruana
and kirill alexeyenko so what happened
in this game by the way wanted to
mention if you think the f3 nimzo
is sort of this offbeat you know maybe
it's tricky but it's not that good
line for white fabiano caruana world
number two
is playing it in the candidates so this
is the stuff
i'm telling you put the pressure on
black with the f3 and enzo
so we got this position of course a3
alexandco
does go bishop e7 e4 d takes e f takes e
and then e5 played 307 times in my
database
was not alexanko's choice instead the
very
interesting c5 was played and
while this move is very much offbeat
very much
not the popular choice i think this is
just a better move than e5 i think after
e5
d5 white is very often getting some sort
of advantage or at least
a lot of pressure on the position but c5
may be equalizing
i am struggling to find lines that prove
an advantage for white
so i'm going to instead recommend
something that i think is
reasonably simple for white that doesn't
require too much studying and
does still pose some problems to black
even if black is able to solve those
problems with accurate play that being
said this is
appeared 19 times in my database i'm
sure if you ask you know some mega
databases it'll be in there a few more
times
but this move definitely the offbeat
choice so what happens here well
again we want to maintain our pawn
center so d5
is going to be the choice and black's
idea is to take on d5
with the e pawn so a wildly different
approach than what we have been seeing
for the first part of this lecture
but a pretty good approach for black
nonetheless
uh white now has a decision uh knight
takes d5
is never going to be correct because i
think we're just hanging upon among
other reasons
but c takes d5 or e takes d5 and both
moves have been tried
i think after c takes d5 though it is
actually going to be black who has
the advantage why is black gonna have
the advantage here well this e pawn
especially lacking an f pawn for support
is going to be a bit of a target and
black should be able to maintain control
over the e5 square this just means
white's gonna have a long and difficult
road ahead
defending these two central uh the
central pawn duo
and i don't think this is what you want
out of life with white
so i like the move e takes d5 which was
played in this game by fabi
so following fabi's prep so far probably
can't be a bad idea
king side castles by alexanko and then
bishop e2 by fabi is very sensible
putting a blocker in the way on the e
file
and here alexanko plays a quote-unquote
novelty i believe i think this is the
first serious game
where rookie 8 made an appearance
previously
bishop d6 had been getting played and
here i think the accurate choice uh as
shown
by matlikov in a game he had in 2019
i think the accurate choice is knight b5
what's the point
well the point is after a6 you simply
take this bishop off on d6
and then i'm not really going to spend
too much more time here because
basically the lines that you see here
are going to look very similar to what
we got in
the actual game except that white has
gotten rid of the dark squared bishop
and probably
is getting a better version of the game
position
because of this this trade so
bishop d6 allowing knight b5 maybe
wasn't what alexandra had in mind and
instead
he chose the move rook to e8 fobby
develops naturally with knight f3
and black applies some pressure down the
e file with bishop g4
white is just in time to castle king's
side though so far
so natural for white nothing too crazy
that we're looking at
alan senko now continued with the move
knight
b to d7 and here fabi came up
with the really interesting move of d6
now i don't think d6 was required by
fabi if you were looking for something a
bit
simpler well i i sort of had bad news
in in that this position is just not
simple um
what is sort of the character of the
position well white has pressure
down the f file has a very strong pawn
on d5
has some more central control but there
is some airiness
around this king right there's some
squares on the e
file that black is going to look to take
control of this h2 pawn may come under
fire
this diagonal may also be weak and this
is sort of black's play
against uh against white's position here
but if you want a few sort of general
moves general steps that you can take
to sort of naturally get developed i
think bishop e3 queen d2 is a perfectly
fine way
for white to develop h3 is often a
useful move
with the point that after takes you can
take either with the rook or the bishop
and even coming out with bishop g5 queen
d2 rookie one
this is sort of a simple way to approach
the position you just want to
sort of contest uh the e file make sure
you're keeping your pawns under control
and you can kind of just play the
position from here
um like i said this line is a relatively
new thing right
it's sort of only now getting some play
at these top levels
so there's a lot left unsaid so to speak
here this is
a line that has not really been analyzed
to death one way or the other yet
and probably we just have to wait for
players like fabi caruana to keep
playing it
a bit longer to uh to figure out what is
actually going on here
but yeah if you want something simple
play something like h3 just develop your
pieces and in white should be fine in
this position
is black any worse i sincerely doubt it
but white definitely has a playable
position
and it's it's going to be a complex game
going to be a complex game
in the game though fabi does find this
move d6 which
may be useful to sort of
play for it for some kind of advantage
uh the only move now is is bishop f8
for black by the way i do want to
mention if bishop d6 here this idea of
knight b5
still does exist and i think this is the
reason why alexenko was avoiding playing
bishop d6 this entire game
i think this knight b5 and taking off
this dark square bishop
can introduce some ideas for white to
sort of begin taking the dark squares
back right and if that happens for white
then i think black may very seriously be
worse so
if bishop d6 knight b5 is almost always
going to be a good idea for white which
is why we saw knight bd7 d6 in the game
bishop f8
now fobby still continues with this move
h3 just a good move in general forcing
this bishop to make a decision bishop h5
or takes on f3
if takes on f3 then bishop takes f3 is
even better
in this scenario because fabi has
already opened this diagonal
so we see bishop h5 by lexanko and now
the move i've been talking about
knight b5 comes on the board anyways for
fobby
and this is sort of fabi's attempt to
pose some problems
to black what problems well these
problems
right this is not nothing this is a fork
of two rooks that is not easy to avoid
and directly after this move on move 15
i think alexenko was
out of his prep as i believe was fabi
and alexanko just
sort of already makes a critical mistake
that gives fabi the
advantage i think perhaps the best way
to play
is either with queen b6 or rook b8
either of these moves i think
they do eventually transpose and
what's the point the point now is if you
continue
with something like knight c7 rookie 4
is going to be quite powerful
why is rookie 4 powerful well because
you want to take on f3
go rook d4 and collect this pawn back
here on d6
turns out this is not an easy idea to
stop the best fob you could do
is bishop d3 when suddenly things look
bla bad for black
but black is getting more than enough in
this exchange sacrifice
the dark squares are collapsing and
this is probably playable for white but
but i would be very very afraid
i don't think white is too much worse
here but again just going to be
insanely complicated from here on out
so i think a little bit simpler for
white might be bishop f4 just keep the
game going
something like a6 knight back to c3 to
stop rookie four
and again it's just going to be a game
for example something like
queen b6 queen d2 and
like i said a lot left unsaid here this
is a position that has never been
reached
and it is very very unclear uh in this
position still
what is going on uh all i know it's
going to be complicated the ideas for
white i at least can tell you
are basically just contest this e file
maintain this pawn on d6
and try to activate your pieces with
something like g4
moving the knight out of the way pushing
bishop f3
and moves such as this so a lot left
unsaid
in the game though rookie 6 was played
and now we actually just get a worse
version
of this knight c7 line for black after
bishop f4
a6 knight c7 rook e4 so black has now
done a little bit of a stutter step in
this extra tempo is going to cost black
here
fabi chose bishop h2 which is enough for
an advantage even if it wasn't the
simplest way
for an advantage apparently queen d2 is
better but bishop h2 was good enough in
the game
rook c8 and now g4 and the point here
is that this rook has nowhere to go
along this uh
along this e file so alexanko decided it
was time for a sacrifice and took on g4
now after bishop d3 knight h2 takes on
e4 takes on f1 takes on f1 takes on d6
knight d5 it turns out that
this piece for three pawns is very much
going to favor
white now is this something that you
need to memorize need to learn for
opening theory i don't think so
this idea as i said is very much
not the most common in the position and
as i also said um
put as much work as you want into this i
will say
uh personally myself i think this level
of understanding is enough
uh if you want to go out and play the f3
nimso and maybe
wait a year see how many more games we
actually get in this line because i have
a sneaking suspicion
that it will not be zero i think this is
a a line that has a very definite future
at the top level of play in the f3 nimzo
so keep an eye out for this one just to
recap
what we're talking about how did we get
here the idea of c5 instead of e5
for black is an interesting one d5 ed5
is the idea
we respond with e takes d5 castles and
now we just develop
normally on the king's side get castle
as quickly as possible
if bishop d6 ever happens we're applying
knight b5
and taking this piece off the board and
in the game
fabi's big idea was to go d6 and
develop like this asking black some
pretty difficult questions so any
questions
on this variation uh and questions that
i can answer
because this position i'm not gonna lie
i could have spent
20 hours analyzing this and not come to
a definite conclusion
which is probably why we're seeing it
played at the top level um
but let me know what you guys have
questions
on in this position
on this position specifically
why not g4 here instead of d6 from right
what if we go e4 or
d5 what if we go e5 first and then d5 ah
yes so that's a good question
um why not g4 here uh it's just a little
bit too weakening i think
it's a little bit too weakening you're
not really getting anything with g4
in the previous position sorry i should
i should look at the game a bit here
um here we're playing g4 because if you
go bishop d3 first
then this square becomes available to
black
i believe actually the tactics are a bit
more complicated the idea is knight e5
here
and the point is eventually rook d4
becomes available to black
so white was only playing g4 here to
make this idea of bishop d3 work i don't
think this is a general move that is
that is good for white
um it just it even further weakens the
king's side
so much so that black felt comfortable
sacrificing a piece for it
why not knight e4 for black well 94 is
actually a really important move
to to keep in mind here it's always
going to be a relevant idea
but in this case of course it just
doesn't respond to the threat
of of knight c7 so yeah the problem with
knight b5 is
in fact weakening some squares like e4
for example rookie 4 is in the game
knight e4 that you mentioned but
in this case the the exchange is going
to be enough to combat the idea of
knight
to e4 but but yeah it's going to be a
complicated position the best i can i
can say
is develop your pieces try to go rook a
to e1 and be mindful
of weaknesses like the c4 pawn while
contesting the e file
and you will get a definite chess game
it's going to be an interesting one
i sincerely doubt you're going to have
any boring games in
in this line
okay let us move along then because i do
have one more line
that i want to mention and for some
reason in the f3 nimzo
i think the best lines are always the
least popular that is the best lines for
black
are always the least popular which in
general is is good news for us we get to
play against all the bad lines with the
white pieces
but the bad news for me is that these
really interesting ideas for black have
very few games in them and i have to
work very very hard
to to understand them so in this game we
saw bishop e7
with the idea of c5 only 19 games in the
lead chess database on c5
and it is a very interesting idea so
interesting that it appeared in the 2020
candidates
now there is another idea here which is
incredibly to put the bishop on d6
rather than e7 so let's take a look at
it
let us see we have d4 knight f6
c4 e6 knight c3 bishop b4 f3
all the same moves and then bishop d6
and at first glance
this move actually looks like a little
bit of nonsense
but what's actually going on here uh
well i mentioned this move
at the top of the hour if you remember
and i talked about why
if black wants to go this with this move
c5 then they should put the bishop
on d6 and let's examine why that
is well if you put the bishop on e7
and try to go c5 then it turns out this
move e5
is going to be good for uh
four white here uh why is that well
after knight fd7
white is happy to take on d5 and i think
this
should be a bit better for whites and if
you go c takes d4
this is just going to be a piece
sacrifice because now white is gaining a
tempo
against this bishop on e7 now compared
to this idea of bishop d6
if you go e4 c5 now this is a bit of a
trap
the move e5 is actually going to be
significantly better
for black why is that well
now after the same move c takes d4 you
don't really have time to take either of
these pieces
because there's no bishop on e7 to gain
a tempo on
and black would recapture the piece on
c3 and if you go queen
uh takes d4 seemingly renewing the
threat there's the move knight c6 when
you are just losing your e5 pawn
so that's the main point of this idea of
bishop d6 it's to follow up
with c5 here i should mention
c5 is not forced and black is well
within their rights to just take on e4
and go e5 with
very similar ideas to what we've just
seen
that being said i think this is going to
just transpose back to all the lines we
looked at before
potentially directly with bishop c5 here
or as we saw
black doesn't have to play bishop c5 but
white can play very very similarly
just getting the pieces developed and
castling
queen slide as normal pushing on the
king side like we've seen before
and lastly i feel i should mention this
idea of c5
because at first glance of d5 it may
look as though
black is getting a better version right
we saw black wasting a full tempo to
bring the bishop back to d6
in this line but here actually the move
e5
is going to be playable with the point
that after c takes d4
queen takes d4 knight c6 there's no pawn
on d5 the stop queen takes d6
so that's it for for the nuances here
now
the main idea of bishop d6 is c5 just
felt i should at least mention
why these other lines aren't really
working with the bishop on d6
the only real idea in my opinion is c5
and i want to give a little bit of a
shout out here the first time i realized
that this line existed
was when we had the one and only el
shawn moradian body as grand master in
residence
and he mentioned this idea to me and
he's actually played it in a game before
so he is the one who made me aware of
this
and uh yeah el shawn had a good idea
because this line i think is very very
dangerous
for white if you don't really know
what's going on
so i think white is almost in danger of
being worse
if you play the move c takes d5 why is
that
it doesn't look like such a big deal at
first glance but after
c takes d4 if you play the move which
has been played against
el-shan which is queen takes d4 i think
after ed5
knight d5 knight d5 queen d5
castles uh for example bishop eth
well sorry this wasn't elshon's game
trying to find elshon's game
um e takes d5 was played against al-shan
castles knight ge2
ricky eights bishop g5 bishop e5 queen
d2
knight pd7 just for example
white's pawn on d5 is going to end up to
be a
a little bit of a weakness here and
black's pieces are all developed very
very comfortably
it's very unclear what white is doing
with this bishop or this king
and i think black has some advantage
here i think this is a good pawn
sacrifice
for black so all of that is to say i
don't think white's best choices to take
on d5 because takes on d4 is actually a
very serious move
so with that in mind the move i'm
recommending is d take c5
and the point here is that we just
eliminate this option by black entirely
and now after bishop takes c5 the only
real move
we can in fact go cd5 with white
now if e takes d5 the idea
that i have is not necessarily to take
on d5
sort of accepting upon sacrifice and
trying to develop
that this is what else opponent kind of
did but i think the move e5 here
is quite dangerous for black and i think
this is going to be white's best option
to continue the game uh what's the point
well after knight fd7
for one you can take this pawn and there
are actually a few
old old old games in this exact line for
example one between boris elephant and
boris baskey
but i think uh even better here for
white is to just go with simply
f4 now why is this so much better than
the lines we just looked at
well by not taking the time to take on
d5
instead of being up a pawn but with a
weakness with a weak king
now material is even but black is the
one with the weakness on d5
white has a little bit more leeway to
sort of develop out with knight f3
bishop e2 just just for example
and i think white is going to be
slightly better here the play could
continue with something like knight b6
and knight f3 and
now the point for white
is that you're taking over the d4 square
which is an idea we've seen before for
example b4 bishop b7 bishop b3
and white is once again in control and
it is black
with the weakness on d5 so
what's my remedy to this idea of bishop
d6 well you go d take c
bishop takes c5 and you take on d5 with
the point that after e takes
you go e5 f4 and develop normally
that being said there's one last trick
that i want to cover and it's not really
a trick i think it's just a good
decision
by black and the point is captures are
not forced in chess
and after c takes d5 black has the
option to just castle
but i do think this is going to be a
better
extra pawn for white than what we saw
against uh
or in el shawn's game and i think the
simple move here d takes e6 is perfectly
fine
for white there is one game here between
sergey volkov and evgeny
shaposhnikov and that went queen e7
when white was slightly better after an
eventual e takes f7
just taking a few too many pawns for
white
just to show you how that game went
queen e7 b4
knight a4 takes on f7 queen c2
and white did just barely manage to
develop all the pieces here bishop d3
g3 and then eventually you know black
goes a bit crazy starts sacrificing
pieces
but it was not enough to defeat the uh
wonderful sergey volkov who ended up in
some you know absolutely ridiculous
position here
with two rooks for the queen after
bishop takes a4 but a winning position
nonetheless so what's the takeaway well
i i
am not even going to bother to analyze
all the lines after d takes e6 here
i think bishop takes e6 is is a bit of a
simpler try although it does allow white
to trade the queens which is why black
didn't do it in
that game but the point is white's going
to get an extra pawn black's going to
have some pressure
and white just needs to find some way to
get developed
that being said there are exactly zero
games after bishop takes e6 and this is
very
much a sideline in this opening so i
didn't want to spend too much time
what's the key points to remember in
bishop d6 well
after e4 our main idea still rings true
we are going to
take on c5 not d5 and then take on d5 to
follow
and our point is when black recaptures
which i think the vast majority of
people are going to do
you go e5 f4 and knight f3
if black castles then you just take on
e6 maintain your extra pawn
and look to develop your pieces this is
going to be um
not the most comfortable pawn of all
time for white but it is an extra pawn
and definitely a lot to play here a lot
to play for here
with both sides so any
lasting questions on this idea of the
perplexing
bishop retreat after this move a3 any
final questions that you guys have for
me
what you got
volkov again why is it not called the
volkov variation you've got me beat
there jorge i don't know
c5 next week likely i will go over c5
there is there are a couple other things
i want to do as well
but c5 i think is is really really
important
um okay no more questions well then i
want to do a very brief recap of
everything we've covered so far
because i think we did uh cover more
lines tonight than we have in any other
night so a recap may be in order
just a reminder we started off with uh
nakamura against magnus carlsen
and that game went bishop e7 e4
and the idea here was the popular e5
with the point of bringing the bishop to
c5 putting pressure here
i recommend the move order with knight
f3 and
while this doesn't love knight g4 it
does not allow
bishop d4 which i think could very
seriously kill the game for white
bishop g4 was the main idea trying to
battle for this square
white's not going to give it up though
we take with the queen
and now we can respond to bishop d4 with
knight e2 at any moment for example
knight bd7 bishop g5
castles transposes back to the game
queen slide castles for white
and now after bishop d4 in c5 the point
here for white is to expand
on the king's side with the center sort
of locked
now the idea of the knight g4 idea from
the same position
we have to contest this bishop and then
after
bishop f2 it once again becomes a battle
for this square
with c5 and sorry all the lines got
mixed up in leeches so i just have to
put them on the board
d takes c6 and then bishop d4
is going to be met by the key c7 queen
takes c7 knight d5
queen takes c4 loses to king d2 and
queen d8
white just collects this extra pawn and
is significantly better
the simpler knight takes c6 allows the
queen trade with a
a simpler version of the same we're
still going to challenge the d4 square
if black decides not to go bishop c5 the
play for white is going to be very very
similar
you just develop the pieces out castle
queen's side and push on the king's side
then we took a look at the dangerous
idea of c5 in this position
e takes d5 is going to be our move we
develop simply
and then try and contest that e file try
and consolidate with
our past d-pawn lastly we just finished
looking at the idea of bishop d6 here
with the point of c5 in this position
and once again the key point you take on
c5 take on d5
and go e5 f4 knight f3 with a pleasant
position
for white all right that's going to do
it for us we ran a little bit over time
tonight but we did have a ton
to cover if you're watching live be sure
to head over to the twitch channel where
the fun is going to continue with
tactics time if you're watching the
youtube version or have just had enough
chess for the night understandably
thank you so much for watching as always
my name is caleb denby
and i will see you next time
you